la masturbation en vrai c'est bon pour
la santé j'ai bon pour la santé si tu
souhaites bientôt porter il faut souvent
te brun petit tour d'horizon des
bienfaits de l'auto érotisme la
masturbation c'est un somnifère bio le
corps sécrète un certain nombre de
substances et notamment des endorphines
endorphines ça veut dire morphine
endogène c'est un peu comme si le corps
payait sa tournée de morphine
masturbation ça détend elle calme le
stress et les douleurs aussi donc par
extension la masturbation ça a des
vertus apaisantes anxiolytiques et
antalgique la masturbation c'est bon
pour le cœur ça accélère le rythme
cardiaque donc ça fait travailler le
coeur au même titre qu'une activité
physique modérée d'ailleurs en cas de
maladie cardiovasculaires on peut
reprendre une activité sexuelle normale
à condition d'y aller progressivement
pour réapprendre à se gérer c'est quand
même plus facile d'être tout seul c'est
vous qui avez des problèmes cardiaques
ok on s'y met la masturbation c'est bon
pour la prostate
une étude de l'université de Boston mené
sur 32000 hommes a démontré que ceux qui
éjacule le plus ont moins de risques de
développer un cancer de la prostate